have never done anything with biology
and in my life
I took it in ninth grade and I was
determined never to approach it again
because the problems were way too
complex and also you have to deal well
at least at that time I thought was
human beings not microorganisms if they
had a real good microbiology Chris maybe
I would have looked at everyone but
there are a lot of challenges in this
field a good friend of mine is in
astrophysics switched to doing data
science down in Australia and the first
project he was assigned to was to work
with some of the biologists down there
and he said my god it's like they're 15
years behind where we were and and they
don't have the computational tools that
they need and this is a real challenge
and this echoes comments that sarah has
told me over the years about the field
about how people collect data about how
people even just annotate the data how
the experiments are run and all the
challenges associated with it
she is 0bs and that is what I love most
about Sarah is that when I ask her
opinions about quality of work and
people in various position divisions at
our lab she can tell them to me
straighten and I absolutely a hundred
percent believer and so I think the
approach that she's taking here is
really exciting for this field it is in
its nascent stages I would say and there
is a tremendous amount of potential here
so thank you sir thank you I hope to
easier in a little slowly to something
that is I you haven't had a biology talk
I apologize you have not okay well I
will try to ease you into it
it's a an interesting parallel honestly
when people ask me why I study bacteria
I always tell them that I
to meet aliens I watched a lot of Star
Trek I really wanted to make first
contact and as I grew older I had to
accept that I was not going to get shot
into space to meet aliens but luckily
for me the aliens are here bacteria are
the most alien form of life on the
planet that is a bacteria called mix
Akaka sansa it moves through the soil
crust it prefers to eat equal life
it likes to bump up it's like a Saturday
Night Live skit remember the guys who
just go up to ladies and baby don't hurt
me it just vibrates itself against the
cells until they lice and then it eats
them when it backed tracks along its
slime mold that it leaves behind it
forms these blooming bodies where half
of the bacteria die to feed the other
half so they form spores and when people
first observe this is a very old graph
they thought they were fungus here so
complex they have some of the biggest
genomes among bacteria this is really
strange and we know nothing about that
we know that anti-cancer drugs come from
them because they have to coordinate
across cells
so there's secreting compounds that
communicate with each other we cannot
get them to change when they do that or
how they do it or the components with
which they do it they are very alien
they're living their own lives here's my
favorite piece of information I read it
out of a book from 1920 about this
bacteria if you want to go catch or
capture some in the wild you should use
wild rabbit poop not domestic rabbit
poop there's a difference what is the
difference no one has bothered to track
down that for me this is a very
pertinent clue in what these bacteria
are doing why they're doing it and how
we could get them to do it for us more
efficiently than just out in the wild
but we haven't got that data here is the
basis of biology you have to remember
and then forget for this talk is that
everything has DNA and that is the
easiest thing to read about it as
absolutely the easiest thing you can get
a sequence data it didn't always that
wasn't always the case when we got all
together to do the human genome and
every other genome it was not easy to do
sequencing that was a huge effort that
took a lot of people all over the world
to bring that technology down to
commodity but now they have so we were
really shocked when it turned out that
humans for 3 billion bases had fewer
genes then
Wurm know the data the sequence is
really interesting dimension of things
but it is so much easier to read than to
understand so right now we have run
ahead of ourselves we are sequencing all
kinds of environments and we get this
DNA ask them what it does and besides
make a pine tree they don't know they
don't know we have not broken it down
this is one of the fundamental
challenges that I hope to begin
approaching is how can we actually turn
all that information into knowledge so
think of it I want you to think of a
genome all that sequence data that we
can get about any organism as a cookbook
I want you to think about it as a
collection of successful recipes from
history so these that that's obviously
not a photograph of a dinosaur but the
dinosaur still live today we just call
them birds right the and a bird's genome
is a collection of the recipes that
worked well together to get it to today
if you read its bird genome though and
just get the sequence that does not
necessarily tell you which bits are
still good which bits are just still
hanging around and used to be good and
which bits are good in certain
situations like the bird needs to lay an
egg but doesn't have enough calcium or
the bird is wet or the bird is suddenly
swimming you do not know which things
are working just by looking at a static
shot of a TCG we do not have the
information for that well if the genome
is a cookbook the planet is a library
this is really a replaceable information
and so sequencing is a good start I am
NOT trying to slam sequencing but it is
not enough it is like writing stuff down
in a language that you can only have
read we still don't know what it's
saying the other thing is that no
organism is an island and we're
constantly changing each other this is
where function becomes really really
important when and why are we actually
using sequence and what does that
sequence actually mean there are more
bacteria on this planet than anything
else except for viruses there's more
viruses on this planet than anything
else and we still don't know what the
sequence they're carrying around and
changing is doing
agriculture however gives me hope
agriculture is the original genetic
engineering experiment and it was
undertaken without any sort of
regulatory oversight at all by termites
and damselfish these fish will pick out
fungus they don't like growing in corals
so they can plant an invasive fungus
that they do like to eat tell me that's
not farming by doing this they are
changing the genomespace of the coral of
the fungus everything adjusts for this
insult to environment there's monkeys
now in Japan then apparently our
training dear they hear the call they
feed the deer they ride the deer around
they have other behaviors with the deer
that are interesting to animal
behaviorists ants it been milking aphids
school kids know that ants milk a feeds
those termites have fixed this fungus
the same way we do fix a population
genome so well that it breeds true just
basically made it clonal those termites
did that you can't have control over an
organism you can influence its behavior
without really understanding the
sequence function thing it just takes
forever and we've done it so all of
these are the same species these are all
mustard but you select over time for the
flowers and you get cauliflower you
select over time for the stalks and you
get kohlrabi you select over time for
color and you can get Kaela cabbage but
they're all technically still the same
species and you crossbreed them and in
the 80s you get something like
broccolini so we're we have pretty good
control over these functional things in
this plant even though we still don't
know which DNA sequences are doing each
part so of course we've done it on a
larger scale to write all of these
things except for the cat we would
consider domesticated a cat can't be
domesticated because I leave it in the
backyard it will go catch stuff and
sustain itself if I leave the dog in the
backyard he needs to find a patron
pretty quick so that's the difference
for me between tame and domesticated
this is great bioengineering this is
really great bioengineering and we
really accept that this is
bioengineering and we have managed to
make lasting changes in these organisms
they don't look like they do in the wild
one of the things that happens when you
domesticate organisms as they start to
turn white which is really weird and
nobody knows exactly why they start to
exhibit especially in dogs more
immature behaviors like child puppy-like
behaviors because they're dependent on
you we're not allowing them to reach a
full maturity so definitely changes in
the DNA that we are doing over time
we're definitely seeing that when it
comes to microorganisms we seem to slow
down yeah I would think that we're
domesticated does that mean we're
becoming us for sure how long does it
take kids to move out of their parents
home now osteo before there's good size
and bad sights I'm not saying it's bad
to hang out at your parents till you're
21 and definitely that's there's also
cultural things but yeah it's a mark of
wealth or resources that are being put
into the system how quickly you have to
be going and getting your own resources
so I think that's the point is that a
genome is not a static thing ever when
it comes to microbes we have really sort
of narrowed our repertoire so these are
all products that we get from pretty
stable microbes so you get your beer
from yeast we've been working on that
used for 6,000 years for beer and bread
xantham gum all of xanthan gum on the
planet is made in the bacteria called
Xanthomonas campestris pickles that
whole process is controlled by bacteria
that really ancient food preservation
technique is about the right bacteria in
a jar and the way you make sure you get
the right bacteria is to make it really
acidic and they make it acidic and you
preserve that that's how you get pickles
I saw you putting a ton of soy sauce on
your lunch today that's the yeah all
bacteria and yeast yeast ferment the soy
sauce but all msg on the planet is made
in bacteria current a bacterium glutamic
them all of it 100% it's way cheaper to
do it that way she's streptococcus
thermophilus other associated fungi I
mean you get that really nice ripe stuff
that's some really nice right
microorganisms olives this is I am NOT a
big olive fan I always say this is a
plant that is trying really hard to get
us not to eat it because you have to
process it very heavily and a lot of
that process involves bacteria so then
you get into things like well vinegar
obviously is acetic acid bacteria
you start to get into medicines and this
is where we've probably made the most in
the least inroads erythromycin is one of
those antibiotics that the World Health
Organization says if your country
doesn't have it you are in trouble it's
a very basic antibiotic very effective
still and it's only made in a bacteria
called sacra palace for Eritrea there's
no chemical synthesis route for it so in
order to get this antibiotic you grow up
a bunch of bacteria and then break them
and take the antibiotic out it's the
only way to do it this is an immune
suppressant that comes from a bacteria
it's the only way to make it is to grow
bacteria and get it out they cannot edit
these bacteria they can't reach in and
say can you make more in the same way
that we well I'll get to that this is
just the state of the art right now is
some of these bacteria we've been
working on for thousands of years and
we're still not exactly sure exactly
what makes them so good at this we just
sort of bread them like dogs so the
history of bioengineering fits on one
side we discovered DNA in RNA makes
sense now we can copy DNA the DNA and
the RNA encode proteins you guys have
heard the you know codons you have a T C
and G in the DNA and you take that long
string of a T CS and G's and in certain
sections of the genome you can read them
in groups of three called a codon so ATG
means the methionine amino acid and then
ata would mean the isoleucine amino acid
and so this forms a code that you
translate into proteins and the proteins
then take on a secondary structure they
get folded and they actually now have a
mechanism of action so the shape that
they take on informs the action that
they take in the cell if you change the
DNA you change the protein you change
the protein structure you change the
proteins function so now everyone's
excited okay we're still not it at a
multicellular animal there we're not
even at a single cell
oh no this is all inside every cell on
the planet no matter what kind of animal
it is or a single cell or you everything
works like this Dogma says that the
other stuff is is derived in some way
with some kind of environmental
interaction with some kind of that
environmental interaction aclu's in a
multicellular case interaction with each
other coordinate yeah so so there's
there's more of this and that's just
protein no no cell walls say friends oh
yeah that's that's where you get into mo
I can explain organelles organelles are
cells that used to be independent that
got subsumed into another cell and then
just lost independence does that make
sense it's just just not questioning but
trying to understand how how much da how
much how much does it
how much dogma coming from the DNA
cursor winds up governing physiology oh
it's all still context dependent so your
protein is going your DNA is absolutely
going to say eighty GGC GA right but
when it gets read into RNA there are
mistakes when the RNA gets translated to
protein there are mistakes and then when
the protein folds there can be mistakes
now if your protein folds at a pH
slightly higher even if everything else
was perfect your protein can take on a
different conformation and work
differently it's completely structure
dependent can you have two different
proteins to take on the same shape yes
yeah and this is a huge area of
computational and modeling quite is how
can you predict what shape a protein
will take just from the sequence and
that's an unsolved problem you can't we
cannot predict what so no one know and I
don't know care what you've heard from
synthetic biologists know is designing
jeans from scratch they can't we are so
unable to predict how DNA will turn into
protein in the end like what DNA
sequence will form what shape in the
chemical activity space that we just
borrow genes that we've seen and from
all over the planet and try to tweak
them
we do not start here and design
backwards never happens could you say
that because it's context dependent
depends on the sort of cellular reactor
within which those proteins welcome
welcome which is a form of epigenetic
memory yes so the state we are in now
has depends on the state we used to be
in and that's not necessarily encoded in
the DNA it just feeds back to it right
so if you happen to look into a state
that's good your DNA will remember that
part for the next state and it's why I
tell people that cells our information
and memory the memory is the DNA but are
the informations of DNA but the memory
is the cellular state and there's a lot
of stuff in there that cannot be coding
DNA and it's just being passed down from
successful cell to successful cell this
is why I don't work in viruses they kind
of freak me out
viruses are just information they have
no memory very little memory so you can
I can email you a virus you can print it
out have it synthesized by someone and
they'll give you the actual DNA you put
it into a cell and virus pops out I
cannot do that with a cell because the
cell is dependent on a state of
information that it inherited from
another cell we might never get to your
talk so protein folding is driven by
like electrostatic forces so isn't that
reversible can't you just
you can definitely unfold a protein but
when you refold it will it take on the
same shape what this is a chaperone are
other proteins that the cell makes that
ensure that certain proteins fold
properly and those chaperones sometimes
only get expressed when the cell is
stressed out so if you heat up a cell
it'll start making chaperones to make
sure certain proteins don't fold wrong
because of the heat
I just committed see people ask you
about prison protein building they might
want to look at the fovea that bony
project that was a very interesting one
something like $50,000 on the page
really yeah you can download software
that will run on your computer and idle
time that will work on some of these
problems because it's molecular dynamics
you can model all the individual
chemical interactions but it still has
to be proven that the model is right by
going back and they actually
crystallizing proteins and obviously
that's very difficult problem because
you might be able to crystallize or even
solubilized protein but is that actually
the state it has in the self which has a
very different environment because the
whole point of a being a cell is in it's
keeping homeostasis which is not
necessarily conducive to crystallizing
something and taking an x-ray of its
structure so biology is a difficult
science but this is how you might think
of bioengineering aswer trying to have
an impact on the DNA so in history when
we're domesticating things our impact on
the DNA has been entirely from that
puppy is friendlier than that puppy so
I'm gonna breed them to that other
friendly puppy and hopefully whatever is
going on in the DNA and the friendliness
is going to come in there the next
letter and over litter over litter over
litter we're changing we're fixing
things in the DNA that has been the best
approximation we've had until the
molecular biology age when we started to
be able to say I can actually go in and
legit turn that T into an A I can do
that at the DNA level now let's see what
happens next because when people are
selectively breeding they don't know
whether what they're preserving is the
history as you separate it into
information in history they don't know
whether they're selecting for the
information or for the history right
they do know which traits are heritable
because they can see it right you can
see but the heritability doesn't in
itself tell you where it's encoded yeah
no it doesn't mistakes there's
definitely that there's also a very
broad ambiguity what I like to tell
people and I go out and talk to people
who are anti GMOs quite a bit and I
respect that position I understand it
one of the arguments I have is that if
we had the same tools for DNA editing
when we were making the dog I could make
you a golden retriever without hip
dysplasia because when you select for
the DNA so broadly by individual your
along everything that's linked to it so
the gene you care about is up here and
it's right next to a gene for chondrite
of cartilage formation so you're picking
for this but you're bringing along that
because they're so close and it's you're
noticing that both are heritable and
something but this you care more about
it's a very imprecise act breeding and
that's why it takes so long you throw
away a lot of ones that are great but
not perfect and that's just how it's
been until molecular biology came along
we started stealing tricks from bacteria
and being able to go edit the DNA
directly and that was supposed to be the
promise of really teasing out which bits
are where and then bioengineering
doesn't know how to access you're
talking maybe about epigenetics which is
the study of information that is encoded
and an inheritable but not in the DNA
yeah that's called epigenetics one big
example is mitochondria which are passed
down from the mother and it's not DNA
the mitochondria do have their own DNA
in them but the mitochondria you get
when you're first just a single cell you
got them all from your mom
so it's heritable but it's not DNA and
it has a big impact if you get diseased
mitochondria you will have disease we
this has been a big limit in
bioengineering and I don't do
multicellular organism bioengineering
for exactly this reason this is this is
a whole minefield of function sequence
if you still can't tell which pieces of
the DNA have which function you
definitely don't know which function
belongs to not the DNA but a good
example would be the cell walls and
organelles like mitochondria they're
inherited that is definitely information
it's getting passed along in the cell
that is not encoded in the DNA and yeah
bioengineering doesn't really have an
answer for that yet in some senses they
would say they don't have to because the
engineering is about the outcome but
you're eating GMO Tomatoes you are
eating plants that have been genetically
engineered you'd have pets in your house
that have been genetically engineered
and they're working fine so now we're
getting really we're getting Quigley but
what happened now I told you we can edit
DNA directly maybe the microbes it's a
lot easier than in your dog or your cat
but we still don't have glowing
buildings we do not have biofuel at
scale at a price point that's
competitive with petroleum we're missing
antibiotics we are still farting which
is entirely controlled by microbes what
what's really happened and the problem
that we have that we have to start
approaching with better information and
learning is hype and DNA is not a code
even I used the word it's encoded it's
encoded we made a mistake and we let
people think that DNA was a code we kind
of ran with that metaphor so now I can
program DNA it's gonna do what I want
that's not what DNA is for I that's why
I told you it's a memory DNA is a
history it is not a programming language
so your metaphor then it goes cells or
information processors DNA is our
programming language and yes I blame
physicists for this DNA sequencing and
PCR allow you to figure out what the
parts are and then you recompose these
into circuits so you steal parts from
all these organisms all over the planet
the each sequence and then you put it
back together in one cell and run it
like hit you've compiled it into DNA and
you hit go and this does not work it has
not worked and it's not working this is
really holding back the Bioeconomy
remember I always tell students an
analogy that saves you time waste
somebody else's money if I had a car
that I said I have better airbags and
I'm gonna put these airbags in this car
and it's gonna take a little bit more
time to make the cars but they're gonna
be safer at the other end none of the
cars going down that assembly line go
you know what I make car babies faster
if I leave the airbags out I'm gonna
have a car baby that leaves the airbags
out and that car baby is gonna have more
car babies faster because it doesn't
need to make airbags and then out the
other end of the assembly line you're
getting cars with no safety features
because it goes fast and they get to eat
more resources this is why
bioengineering is not mechanical
engineering or Electrical Engineering
the number one rule of bioengineering is
that you make imperfect copies of
yourself that is our fundamental rule
cells are not computers at runs circuits
they are self replicators at optimized
four conditions so you design something
you put some DNA in there they copy
themselves in perfectly and then they're
still running this DNA that might now be
imperfect they're still in a condition
or a condition has changed and that is a
selection stamp it is does this DNA copy
does it still work can i still live can
i still replicate and this keeps
happening this happens overnight in
bacteria so you can put your DNA into a
bacteria and in the morning you come
back and you've got this and it bears no
resemblance to what you put in
bioengineering can't be about an
expression of our will on the substrate
it has to be more like domestication
this chassis analysis analogy breaks
down really quickly I said erythromycin
comes from sacra palace for Eritrea you
can believe they've tried really hard to
get e-coli to make it you coli is sort
of like our sidekick bacterias the first
one we really got to know every single
bioengineering student every single
biology student they get to work with
e.coli even in high school in this
country we have made e.coli high school
material they get to put DNA into it
they see it glow in the dark we have
control over bacteria you better believe
they have tried to get that very
difficult bacteria grows and strings has
all kinds of big genome and a lot of
recalcitrants towards cooperating with
people you can bet they've stolen the
genes out of there try to put them in
e.coli and used to try to get them that
are so friendly and manipulable and you
can change the genes and feed them sugar
it does not work it has not worked it
does not work it is not work to put
xanthan gum in it is not work to get the
amino acids for msg and it does not work
for the precursors for plastics and
biofuels they won't do it it definitely
doesn't work when you start to get into
things that cells don't normally make
and you need to start mutating towards
it these guys these old standbys these
models they're not good models for
production it is no different from
saying I see a cow out there eating
grass and making milk but I'm scared of
the horns so I've got a dog here and
they're both four-legged animals this is
actually a better
I you know I wouldn't invest in this
company but if you told me you were
gonna make milk and dogs I feel like
well I can dogs do make milk already
right they're mammals they're those cat
the dog and the cow are more closely
related than the bacteria that we're
putting up opposite e.coli here just
because there are tiny little cells that
look like tiny little cells does not
mean they're in any way related that
they've been separating for as many
years or more as we have from fungi so
what why do people pursue this why do
they continue to pursue this it's really
some we the whole field took 20-30 years
to really pound on e.coli when we first
pulled e.coli literally out of her butts
because it's a biomedical accident that
it's e.coli that we're just looking at
things and sick patients and this one's
there were plenty of other bacteria at
the time that we're also very
interesting but somehow it's just an
accent it was e.coli and everyone
focused on e.coli because everyone else
was using it and so you start debuting
tools you're like look I got it to do
this and everyone starts using that tool
and it only works in e.coli but that's
okay because we're all working on e.coli
and you get to today and everything that
the vendors sell everything that the
students are trained on is all e.coli
and that is like training everyone to
work with dogs and then sending them out
to catch horses baby they can't they
can't do it but if you write a grant to
say oh I'm going to work in this
brand-new bacteria you were out on your
own you don't have protocols for
transforming it for putting DNA and you
don't have protocols for growing it all
of the equipment sold by the vendors
only works in the range for e.coli and
yeast and maybe your guy likes to be
hotter you're gonna have to pay extra to
get an incubator that's hotter the
granting agencies are gonna look at it
and go none of our reviewers understand
like what
why can't you do it any coli that is the
number one question I get asked
everybody is why can't you just use
e-coli so I think the proof is in the
timeline that we learned a lot from it
now it's time to go reproduce that feat
and so I wanted to talk to you guys
about what it's going to take to
reproduce that feat and it motivated by
all of these are functions you cannot
put in e.coli better even cooler than
the ones we've talked about so for the
guy on the top left makes magna
so he can align themselves with earth
magnetic field so we can navigate
himself away from too high of an oxygen
tolerance he's got he's micro air I feel
like he doesn't like a lot of oxygen so
he likes to know which way is up and
down the guy in the top middle you can
sort of see a compartment inside there
it's called an animus ISM that's where
he turns really high rich nitrogen
components into hydrazine and then the
hydrazine it is something else so he
lives in wastewater P lives in P and
turns P in a rocket fuel photosynthesis
at this point is basically a latte these
are cellulose ohms converting all of our
compost any lignocellulose and cellulose
to simpler sugars that can then be
recycled if it weren't for bacteria we
would be hip-deep in our own waste the
guy on the Left makes these little
perfect gas vesicle air bags so he can
control his position in the water column
really interesting superstructures you
saw miksa caucus anthis earlier that's
the baby don't hurt me
bugs that break down e.coli and form the
fruiting bodies these Frankia like to
interface with plants and they're
responsible for most of the pollen after
the last ice age was from plants that
could be colonized by these guys because
they could pull nitrogen straight from
the air and feed it to the plant so when
the glaciers pulled back and left all
that nitrogen poor soil if if the plant
would work with this bacteria this
bacteria took care of them that's still
how a lot of agriculture works we're not
fertilizing stuff is still growing
bacteria just like the bacteria in our
gut plants have the bacteria all around
their roots doing the same thing forth
it's really cool a knock on the root
door and say hey let me in the plant
tries them out lets them in and if they
perform well the plant keeps them and
scabs around them and if they don't the
plant just shuts down the root kills
them no freeloaders around here this guy
makes us perfect nano-layer structure
over the surface of the cell called an S
layer it's just a perfect single
molecule that self assembles into nano
layer sheets just we can't do it we
can't replicate it none of these
functions can be moved into E coli and
you can think of many many many
biomedical industrial physical
applications for all of these things so
why are we still feeding dogs grass that
was the question you spoiled was why is
this still happening
that's cuz you know e.coli is our model
organism we trained everybody on it
and we take infrastructure for granted
there's also the streetlamp fella C
which is you know the tools are there I
have to work there so why are you
working in e.coli I don't know how to
work in sacrifice for you or threa and I
already have the dog bowls the dog food
the dog names I mean they have cute
names for all their projects and stuff
the difference between synthetic biology
and computer science is when computer
science is substrate gets cheaper they
know what to do with it so this is our
mores this is our curve where it's the
price of DNA sequencing and synthesis so
how to read DNA and how to write DNA
it's like how many transistors can you
fit on a chip for biology and the price
is really dropping it is really cheap
that's why I told you week sequence with
abandon we just read sequences all the
time writing them is getting cheap
enough that we're just like hey yeah
just try synthesizing that and stick in
any coli and see what happens but we are
not really figuring out what is actually
happening because as I told you these
sequences don't work in e.coli we want
to be bioengineers so we try to design
build test learn but because of the
sequencing bottleneck sorry the function
bottleneck where we do not know what the
sequence does our curve is lopsided so
why aren't we learning there's no labels
that is 100% the problem we really don't
appreciate bacteria at all either
because back to your gonna fix this
problem for us you see a lot of these
Tree of Life things they got you fold
they think you make you think bacteria
the simplest form of life on the planet
that is not even right they're just as
old as we are they just picked a
different niche to specialize in I don't
like this one much better most of the
things on this tree are things you can
see but the bacteria on this plant I
have a biomass we think equal to all the
plants on the planet that's a huge
amount of organisms to not be able to
manipulate or understand how they're
doing what they're doing they exist in
every niche on the planet five pounds of
you as bacteria and you'd be dead
without them we just bacteria run this
planet we're not even helping
so model organisms are different
non-model organisms are difficult we
want to say okay let's make magnets
let's do photosynthesis but which of
these bacteria do we bring in how do we
manipulate them when we don't have a
roadmap for it and how do you grow them
chiefly because now it's all it's got to
be about the cheap the reason e.coli in
East biofuels have not taken on us
because yeast and e.coli are very
domesticated they like to eat glucose
glucose cost $300 a metric ton you can
get glucose by refining compost and
things but that refinement costs energy
we know that compost and other things
disappears right it gets converted
basically for free
not by eco Larry East if you want to
pair cheap biomass renewable substrates
to something like biofuel production you
have got to be able to feed it for less
than $300 a metric ton because you're
never gonna catch up to petroleum at
that rate so how do you grow it cheaply
how do you feed it cheaply how do you
have cheap inputs and expensive outputs
we have to understand these systems to
build up to complex systems you'll hear
a lot now about the microbiome they say
okay we understand the bacteria running
things but we still can't decompose them
or understand them individually so we'll
just try to manipulate the whole set
which is running before you can walk we
really need to break it down and what
the part I thought you guys would be
interested in was the oddest automated
phenotyping so a phenotype is a set of
an organism's behaviors that is what we
mean by a phenotype the genotype is the
sequence what the sequence says but that
like I said that's easy to read from
sequencing the phenotype that's what you
really need to know to begin to engineer
its behaviors what is it doing under
different circumstances and that is all
the information we don't have remember I
showed you all the plants they're kale
and cabbage and broccoli if you go
decide you want to landscape your front
lawn you can go look up plants that will
grow in this much water in these litter
they call them trophic zones or the the
temperature that gets how cold it gets
at night how much Sun we have
classifications for all those planets
you can landscape your garden with that
much precision none of that stuff exists
for bacteria I want a bacteria that
grows at a pH of 4 just as passed as it
does at a pH of 7 tolerates a salt
constant or
to 5% and excretes x dicarboxylic acid
on a substrate of Manos but not maltose
I can't find it no way to find it and
this is simple stuff its way it's a lot
faster to do than growing plants and
then figuring out how much light it
actually needs yeah my phenotype do you
mean all this does this the structure or
the mechanisms that are responsible for
the structure to the right of the
proteins I mean the proteins themselves
what is that protein for okay so we know
that it has a gene encoded in the DNA
that makes a protein what does that
protein doing what is that protein doing
is that protein using magnesium to cut
DNA is that protein converting one sugar
into another sugar is that what is that
protein doing we don't know is that
protein forming a pore in the cell wall
that allows things and we don't know
that we're not as I'm not as worried
about that I'm gonna take that as a
given I don't need to engineer those
pieces my presumption is that you Cole I
can't do it for lots of reasons
including its cell wall and its
complement of enzymes it's very well
suited to living in our gut and very
poorly suited to living in wastewater
but when I go into wastewater and I find
a bacteria that's doing well there I
will take it cell wall and everything
it's doing well there but I cannot
change this behavior or make it make
something else out of the wastewater
other than methane because I can't
engineer it and I don't understand how
it's doing what it's doing either 1/4 of
the genes and e.coli we still don't know
what they do and we've been studying
e.coli for 80 years so just again just a
test that so then study beta cell wall
there are certain properties of the cell
wall that have sort of a footprint and
the DNA the cell walls a component is
made up of fats and proteins and those
genes that make those are encoded in the
DNA and the mechanism whereby the
spatial distribution gets created we
don't know or I don't know that's
definitely not my specialty is the
infrastructure the structure of cells we
know that bacteria take on different
shapes there's rods there's spheres and
that's definitely something that is
genetically encoded or maybe it's a in
intrinsic into the shape of the proteins
that are forming the things but it's not
clear and some of us because we don't
have the tools to study it because we
don't understand what you're doing like
you know how stem cells and humans can
take on various functions Narus is there
some fundamental bacteria like thing
that can you can you know like some
ancient bacteria maybe that had this
potential built-in I don't think so
stem all of the cells in your body have
all the same DNA they all have the same
genotype even your stem cells have the
same genotype as your what you're
talking about is the difference in
phenotype so your stem cells have the
ability to be pluripotent and to take on
different jobs and by doing that they
differentiate bacteria have a fraction
of the DNA that a single one your stem
cells does there's no ability for them
to suddenly process your urine or
something that if they weren't already
doing that and they specialized it in
just that so multicellularity is a whole
philosophical discussion we should have
at the far about economics of who's
gonna do what and who's gonna get paid
what and that's how we become
multicellular now is it the case that
the history of bacteria is completely
wiped out by the about a billions of
years of evolution so there's no way to
get back at you know the earliest
bacteria or it I'm getting at the origin
of life so this is love that I want to
be able to decompose it into a
simulation where we you hit the button
and you run it and it happens again
right not happening because because life
changed the planet as it changed itself
right the first species to really
threaten global destruction was a
bacteria it oxygenated the planet nearly
killed itself and everybody else and
that change
in what metals were soluble in water
because the oxygen in the atmosphere
changed the course in history of the
planet and it was an accident that that
happened because the ability just
hollering oxygen was an accident that it
happened there's there's a lot of
variables in this I'm not going to say
we can never backtrack to the origin of
life but it is a complex interaction of
genomes and environments and other
genomes and we all act on our each other
and so even me decomposing it to just
I'm going to just study bacteria I am
leaving a lot and because my focus as an
engineer is what can I get them to do
not nest anymore so I'm not trying to
get figure out the meaning of life
anymore I'm trying to harness the life
that's in front of me
effectively but I'd love to talk to you
about it so automated phenotyping all of
that long bio intro was to get you to
the actual okay let's get some robotics
in here so they call me the germ
Wrangler the first thing you have to do
about germs about any organism you're
going to train or domesticate is to
phenotype extensively so you guys have
pets right everybody you can buy a book
about which conditions not to keep your
cat or dog in right
they have optimal temperatures you're
not supposed to feed them chocolate or
garlic we don't know that about these
bacteria we don't know so one of the
reasons we don't know is we went running
ahead of ourselves and sequencing
sequencing is very well automated you
can deposit a sample and it'll get
processed up and slit up and put into
the robots and machines will read it and
the computers will QC it and very few
people need to be involved in the
process anymore but because we're
comparing all of the sequences to E coli
basically and I'm simplifying a bit
there's other organisms that are modeled
at different stages like a rabbit
offices for plants were used for fungus
we go sequence something from the
Mariana Trench and we bring it back and
we compare the genes in it to E coli so
we can guess which ones are genes and
what they do we have never seen the guy
in the mariana trench that we collected
we've never seen him in action we don't
know what his phenotype is so how can we
compare the genes and it turns out that
our RNA this is a really embarrassing
mistake
ribosomal RNA is also encoded in the DNA
these are things that never become
protein it's RNA it never becomes a
protein it just makes RNA but because of
ancient evolutionary hiccups RNA is
absolutely required for the function of
the cell it's very very well conserved
you can spot RNA in bacteria and in
humans it you know what it is there are
in our national databases of DNA
ribosomal RNAs annotated as proteins so
they've read it they looked at it they
were like we think this is a protein and
they put it in there as a protein like a
putative protein and then everybody else
who goes in sequences finds our RNA and
compares it to the no databases they go
yeah that's some protein of unknown
function and they said that matching of
the our RNA in the non redundant
database the false positive rate is like
ninety percent it's it's it's not okay
pfm is a consortium that tries to help
break down understanding of how proteins
work they created a protein family for
RNA and this is a this is not good
that's not good we we are gathering so
much data we have no idea what to do
with it so i this is e coli the most
well understood bacteria on the planet
and i sort of these by putative or
unknown and we still have 806 genes
where the description in e coli is
probably and this is the next best
studied bacteria bacillus subtlest i
call this one the cat because we think
we got it but we don't and it's a 1286
now we're talking about out of 4,000
genes 806 genes out of 4,000
so we can fix this with experimentally
validated annotations yeah so anyone who
sequences within this country federal
money needs to deposit their sequences
and the annotations of those sequences
into NCBI GenBank the National Center
for Biotechnology at the National
Institutes of Health and Bethesda
so these are this is a GenBank database
that's open to the public anyone you can
go there and just search any of the
organism setup in sequence with public
money and some that haven't they were
deposited here to generate the who one
is because what else are you going to do
with them right now it's the sequencing
it's not has not turned into okay now I
can do bioengineering so it's kind of
worthless rely on the researcher to put
this in yes oh yeah yeah the widget
that's a whole other conversation to you
should go out to the joint genome
Institute which is a Lawrence Berkeley
National Lab facility here it's a user
facility where they will sequenced
agricultural and energy related
organisms at no cost to the researcher
if they're in the do a mission and they
have a huge and awesome bioinformatics
pipeline that is dedicated to making
sure as much as we can know about the
sequence gets put in properly so it's
that that whole study is called
annotation so you sequence it and now
you have to literally say a gene starts
here at gene stops here and we think
this gene does this this is not a gene
this is a tRNA this is a ribosomal RNA
it's called annotation and this is our
best source of annotation in this
country so the annotation is technical
and how much is social if I have a paper
published on the genome that I've
sequenced and I've annotated and it's
improving wrong all my papers a chunk my
reputation
I guess that's one way to think of it
what the main problem that I am seeing
and the way I'm targeting it is less
that they don't want it annotated
properly and that they don't there's no
infrastructure to annotate it properly
so to annotate this way by comparison
I said labeling data you you know
everyone's talking about using machine
learning with data you can't do that
with annotations because we don't have
enough functional data for you to
actually build classifiers it all has to
be unsupervised learning
so all annotations done by clustering so
you got your new sequence for your new
organism and you cluster it to known
things and then they say we guess that
this is a putative adhesion and that's
the annotation that you put forth it's
not that you don't want to know what it
actually is or you can't it's just that
it will cost you so much money to now go
in knock it out and see if it stops
ticking the things that you can't so I
don't think that there is an an
unwillingness to reanimate in fact uh
any the the genome databases are pretty
good about re annotating if you get new
data on a sequence and you go hey we
think this is this they will go back and
re annotate everything this is all a
computational effort at this point there
is no actual biology left once you've
got the sequence out it's all
information you can do whatever you want
with it that that's not really a big
barrier it's more that to actually
generate that functional information
takes some elbow grease that no one
wants or it's been able to assemble the
the means for okay so the functions how
how well do you even know what possible
functions can be well you know what the
cell is doing in a broad sense and that
I put this sugar in and I grow it in
these conditions and this came out gas
came out this it changes pH and you can
kind of read those things and say oh
while it did that it made these things
so therefore there must be a gene here
to catalyze this reaction so this sugar
has to enter into the cell membrane so
there must be a transporter the
transporters are kind of easy to see
with the funny
they look like holes right they punch a
hole through and they so the sugar has
to come in and then the sugar has to get
broken down for six carbons to three
carbons so there must be these sorts of
enzymes a lot of these
they're very conserved so if you see it
in one you can spot them I'm not saying
that all annotations are immediately
bunk but when you start straying from
things and looking for functions that
you've never seen before
comparing them to functions you have
seen is not as helpful does that answer
your question
yeah yeah it's another variant on that
set so could you say that what these
annotations are vocabulary of
annotations is hopefully adequate to to
talk about some manner of talking about
the possible reaction dynamics oh yeah
they're they have very good ontology s
for genes and sequences first so in a
sense it's and the reaction dynamics are
sort of described by some kind of a
network yes a label label network with
probably yeah
we have metabolic maps we have beautiful
medibot and some of the very prettiest
ones are from LBL right here so so one
of one of these annotations refers to
say a subnetwork in some sense it's kind
of it's not an atop it's not an atomic
sort of say one annotation might be
talked about this area another
annotation or this area diagram another
annotation just completely yes right
drew a bacterial genome for you they're
circular bacteria tend to freak out with
linear DNA not there's exceptions oh
there's bacteria that have linear
genomes but you'll start reading you'll
get this whole sequence you'll represent
it as a string you don't write and
you'll have a genes here here here in
here and these are all working in the
same set of that metabolic network but
they're very disparate in space how do
you know that they're all in that
network until you have actually seen the
cell working you don't necessarily in
other cases you'll have you'll have
three genes right in a row and they're
definitely we can assume that those are
working on the same section the
metabolic network until it turns out
they're not it's very complex it's very
complex and there's a lot of noise in
here too because the cell doesn't delete
just because it's not using it anymore I
guess the notion of label it seems kind
of kind of relationship I'm using label
as a machine-learning term for function
the proper the proper thing is I don't
know what the function of this is and if
I don't know what the function of it is
I cannot say what the function of the
gene that clusters with it and the next
sequencing experiment is so since I
don't have that label I can't form a
classifier to say with a percent
certainty so you'll notice all of this
putative adhesive it does not have a
what do you call it a it doesn't have a
air bar because we have no quantitation
it's just unsupervised learning
so if label is a technical term in the
machine learning field for let me
actually put some certainty on it so you
said that you have this putative a
decent reasons they trying to be
verified days but they send an expensive
experiment to do and not in e.coli
necessarily but in everything else so
where you could possibly use machine
learning is to look at which papers are
coming out which are lying on which set
of associations and decide that this one
is actually worth going away verifying
because you can validate or invalidate a
huge tons of science you want to go in
with me the this is where I'm headed
I want to go experimentally validate as
many of these annotations as possible
and generate new annotations that you
can back up with an observation because
we need to start working on but we need
to close this gap if we let the sequence
and function gap widen too much more
work I I worry that's that's all I think
I think I've demonstrated enough for you
to maybe share some of my worry so Cole
Turing is possible one of the myths
you'll hear about bacterias oh but so
many are uncultured oh this guy I
recommend reading some of his saltier
papers from his emeritus years Howard
guest he's actually was worked on the
Manhattan Project but then got into the
bacteria which happens
I tell everyone you're gonna end up in
biology you just are but he wrote some
really salty little papers that are very
accessible about how physicists mess up
biology so he's hating on Schrodinger
and the modern myth of uncultured by
bacteria there's no such thing as a none
culturable bacteria they're not eating
moonbeams and stardust so this is a
first myth I usually have to dispel as I
tell people I'm gonna grow every
bacteria that I can and phenotype them
and they go but you can't grow most
bacteria so they are just zombie I don't
know how to explain that one it now that
doesn't mean every single bacteria is
worth growing and it doesn't mean that
they will all grow fast but they are not
uncultured all the next thing to do is
to check their ranges I asked people if
they knew that e.coli can grow in
seawater it's kind of assumed that it
doesn't that's not true it can grow in
seawater that has profound implications
for water processing and bio containment
and things that's this a bacteria you
want to be making biofuel in if it can
get out and survive in seawater no but
if you don't know what its ranges are
how are you gonna do bio containment so
I want to start by demanding more the
data you can typically gather about
bacteria is everything that has an icon
next to it you'll notice there is
nothing here in the this is what I need
to actually grow it range so the reasons
for this are good it's because the bio
medical history of bioengineering has
spent I'm sorry the history by an
engineer EADS meant biomedical the most
money and the highest need has been to
make sure we don't die of these things
not that we make biofuel from them so
all of the stuff up here that you can
find and which is not even everything I
want is basically medically motivated
you need to know this to know how it's
going to go septic or how it's going to
interact with human tissue you need to
know it's graham status because that's a
big divider and which antibiotics you're
going to treat it with you want to know
it's oxygen tolerance because that means
can you get it from a can or are you
gonna get it from free air you don't
really need to know any of these things
to treat it
so bioengineering is lagging on that
biomedical side we need to kind of
establish non biomedical microbiology as
its own thing with these standards and
that's just growing to manipulate it is
a whole other set of things and I put
things here there these are you can get
this information but don't let me fool
you into thinking that this isn't anyway
organized towards manipulation because
it's not yeah I thought that the
philosophy of Medicine is kind of like
shifting toward being more preventive
medicine does that sort of with that
then also naturally create a shift in to
wanting to know more about like how do
you cultivate bacteria so that you can
avoid this condition for the the meta
genome and people's microbiome yeah you
kind of you'll see really papers about
microbiomes where they go say hey we've
figured out every species of bacteria
that's in your stomach what they haven't
done yet they haven't been able to do or
is at what time
after what feeding in which people on
which water sources and which continents
because it will change it changes
dynamically you eat something and your
microbial population is changing and
what it does changes so you could keep
the same microbial population but enter
a different context and they so yes
you're gonna want to start knowing this
but you're gonna have to decompose that
ecosystem because all these bacteria
actually are feeding each other so just
because you pull one out with the reason
they think their own culturable is
because he needed his buddies to feed
him stuff that he does one task in the
ecosystem and then somebody else is
doing another task if you just pull him
out and you don't know anything about
him and you can't read his genotype to
predict a phenotype to say oh i'm gonna
need to supplement him with this
nutrient he's not gonna come out for you
and explain things to you does that make
sense you really we need to gather more
functional data about the stuff that we
can cultivate individually so we can
start cultivating more things so we can
learn more about their function and then
we can start doing some of these really
cool meta-genome experiments so get this
level of mission
to type that does it include the notion
of replication or do you just have to
include replication anyway because you
talked about growing the closest here
would be generation time how long does
it take to replicate itself in terms of
complexity the replication is more more
complex than say pH tolerance I don't
know every the first thing I have if you
can't replicate you die I never see it I
would say I don't even do math on my
experiments the metabolic footprints of
that operation and therefore the genetic
footprints is that's a nice thing
bacteria I've got going is there simpler
so their replication is a little simpler
if there are a lot of moving parts don't
let me lie but it is still genetically
inherited which your generation time is
how much stuff are you moving around and
how fast can you do it and when do you
feel safe to begin replication so tip
again I'm an engineer so I am
abstracting out a layer that I'm not
gonna bother to understand that it just
work and that one is cell replication
okay you caught me
yeah phenotyping is chemical behavior in
context I want to know what it's doing
in every condition and I'm gonna use
robotics to do it I am going to grow
these bacteria at every temperature I'm
gonna grow them in every carbon source
I'm gonna grow them at every pH I'm
gonna grow them with every possible
terminal electron acceptor and I'm going
to see what they do in each of those
conditions which proteins are they
actually making which proteins do they
stop making freeze your friends I'm
going to start with the ones that don't
need friends or they do need friends but
in the lab we accidentally or we take
for granted the fact that we figured out
this guy you have to grow him by adding
methionine he can't make his own Metheny
now in the wild he's living with buddies
and make methionine for him we sort of
abstract that away were like oh yeah
here's the growth medium for this
bacteria if you want to grow it you just
I'm a tiny and most of the time I have
to confess they don't even know it's
methionine necessarily they just know
that they have to put yeast extract in
so used
tract it's a microbiological miracle
food where you grow up a bunch of yeast
and then you kill them all and you dry
that down and feed it to other yeast and
that yeast extract contains all of the
things that were in the yeast that make
life happy like vitamins and minerals
and amino acids and other things trace
stuff and you don't have to know exactly
what your guy needs because it'll be in
the yeast extract you don't know how
much he needs or when he needs it you
just feed him yeast extract
that's called an undefined medium and it
doesn't teach you a lot about what's
actually going on inside your bacteria
so one of the first tasks for us is to
define a media when you define me and
I'll show you the robot I want to use to
do that
you know we we need better label data
this is just an example of how diffuse
our databases are each column is a
different bacteria and then each row is
a different database and what is
designation in that databases so they
all have different names they have
different numbers they have different
designations and a lot of these
databases are just storing the genome
data in this same genome data in a
different database with a different
number it's because genome is sequence
it's been really easy to get so one of
the first things we did was to say we
need to define a way to store this data
in a way that is not like everyone
else's storing it so that we can
actually get at what we're missing and
to compare things that we do know so I
could actually pull out hey this
bacteria in the database that has this
behavior what is the closest bacteria to
it by some taxonomic standards like I
want something that's also grand
positive but is not neck teen on my seat
and also I would like him not to be able
to eat maltose when we're done
populating with this phenotype we'll be
able to do that which will give us a
jump on anyone else trying to engineer
bacteria by just starting with I'm not
sure which one I should use this data
this this will be will be the Facebook
of bacteria basically we'll be able to
pick out exactly who's susceptible to
buying a couch because you show them an
ad so here there has to be robots right
so here's one of the robots that will
make this possible this I took this from
their their literature this is not me
using it it's called a mantis it
actually looks a bit like a premium
and it dispenses liquid in little
amounts so now imagine that you have one
and each one of those tubes that it's
feeding itself from is a different amino
acid a different auxotrophic now you can
test in these little plate to grow the
bacteria in so instead of having one of
my technicians try to remember which
well which amino acid goes into you just
right you just submit an Excel
spreadsheet to this robot all of the
robots I need to do this exist I don't
need to build any I don't need to design
them I just need to harness them in a
manner and gather the data that has not
been done before using bacteria that are
not e-coli
one other thing you have to do with
these bacteria the standard unit for
microbiology and molecular biology is 96
96 wells so standard plate it looks
about this big it's got 96 wells in it
it's terrible for growing bacteria and
then they do it all the time because
high throughput all the robots were
using 96 wells
well they don't shake very well so you
don't get aeration you do not get oxygen
to those bacteria which means they start
behaving in ways that they've only
behaved in when they don't get oxygen
and you go oh great I did a
high-throughput assay and that bacteria
in this well did the best and then you
grow him up with proper oxygen and
shaking and he doesn't do it anymore so
you need to not go for that immediate
scale of 96 wells come back down to 48
at least I like these flower pots or
rosette it so when you shake them you
actually get aeration and they have
these sensors in them right so now I can
read pH I can read through the bottom I
can see how much biomass we're getting I
let the Mantis fill these plates with
various things I put them in a micro
fermenter and shake it overnight and I
have a computer just read what is
bacteria doing over and over and over
and over and over and over again control
like a light source all over the doors
most of these you don't want necessarily
light poor light will change their
behavior and ways that we're not
prepared concentrate on these first yeah
yeah yeah once we've established a
baseline improves some novel stuff then
yeah I think we're gonna go whole how
people come in ask me all the time oh
can you test for this trait that we're
interested in traits there's just not an
infrastructure for reliably de-risking
which one are you gonna bet a million
dollars on an infrastructure for so what
we're trying to do is do you risk all of
it by building an infrastructure for all
of it
so by compiling this kind of data this
is an example of one of these micro
fermenters you put it in overnight and
it just takes pictures of your bacteria
all night long you get a curve out so
I'll be able to say hey when there's
this much methionine they grow like that
and when there's a little more they grow
a little less good then something is
going on there you put it all into a
database in the next step which I'm not
even going to talk about is how you now
use that against gaining their trust and
start co-opting them and domesticating
them so not doing account no we are the
standard in microbiology it's not to do
cell counts but to measure what they
call an optical density in the media
where you know the blank where there's
nothing growing and you just measure the
absorbance at 600 nanometers and just
and you use that as a proxy for how many
how much biomass is in there how happy
the cells are because they're dividing
typically in weapons I don't know it
will also depend on the size of the reef
probably there's there's billions in
there million civilians
sorry biology is still squishy on that
because for us it really matters more
that they're doing something you can
measure their output at the grams per
liter scale then how many there were so
I'm happy that's this is another reason
e-coli hasn't been working for us say
you want any coli to make a compound a
colloid does not normally make a coli is
going to make it because you put the
genes in but it has no way to export it
necessarily so if it's making it inside
its unhappy because it doesn't like this
thing it's building up a lot of this and
it's unhappy the way they get around
that is they let a lot of e.coli grow
they get a huge biomass of it in a huge
fermenter like three thousand liters and
then they send it a chemical signal to
turn on that DNA and make it and then
kill it all so that they had so many
cells up and that's where OD is really
important they're like how many can we
get to grow in this dense environment so
that then we can trick it into making a
lot of this stuff by volume and not
necessarily over time if you make
friends with the right bacteria that
have the secretion pathway you can just
sort of cultivate them and flow and
they'll just continually happily make
something that you carry away from them
because that's how it usually works in
is that these are the reason they make
it is to send a signal to somebody else
these are the words they use to
communicate and even antibiotics or just
words that mean not now or go away or
this is mine or die that's all an
antibiotic is it has to leave the cell
to have an effect
so the OD we use as a sort of proxy for
how happy the cells are by how many of
them there are and we haven't really
worried about exactly how many there you
can see how I'm quantitative we are
already so yeah context is everything
sequence is just one dimension you know
your doggy does eat grass sometimes but
why why is he eating grass it's usually
because he wants to puke right or cuz
he's bored so this is a question that
has confounded me for years that I have
a dog now that he express every time
right before I walk him whereas another
one only ate because he wanted to puke
so I think there multiple reasons reason
I think so
I am I think some just might like the
taste I think they do know some people
to ungraspable huh some people like hops
yeah people like bourbon the future
genome engineering is going to be adding
statistical confidence to our design by
having these phenotyping platforms that
are actually telling us with some
confidence what that sequence does by
function so this is where I'm a very
nascent to these information systems and
automated learning and stuff is I'm
going to try and build this for bacteria
I'm gonna build the robotics automated
burning infrastructure to go say that
gene does this because we saw it 200
times in these micro fermenters that
every bacteria that had this set of
genes behaved like that we can use that
as a statistical confidence that then I
can go hand this gene to somebody or
this bacteria and say now this guy is
good guy to make hydrazine in he's
already there he likes his pH he likes
these ammonia levels now you can start
iterating on that instead that's is a
de-risking and an increase in efficiency
that will help people break out of that
well we have to do it Nikola because
we're guaranteed to get the DNA in
e.coli and we know e coli will at least
try to run it and then we need to have
that same knowledge base that I built
gather the failure
gather the failures and now we will
actually start turning the crank will
get better agriculture if you can get
bacteria to put nitrogen directly into
the plants instead of having to put
hugely overkill amounts of nitrogen and
that just wash out and cause blooms will
can start working on bacteria that are
capable of pulling heavy metals out of
the water they do it for their own
reasons and that for us definitely work
on the farts that would be nice
and of course a really huge problem is
how are we going to work on the
antibiotic problem can we reach in the
bacteria and work on that directly can
we get them to make new structures for
us so that is my top
[Applause]